the question you always have to ask
yourself before you learn something in
any subject is why that's always the
most important question why do we care
about bearings why did we as humans why
did we invent these things called
bearings or even you've got a suggestion
okay bearings enable us to give
directions we can say if you want to get
from A to B here's the direction you
need to face it and then go however far
okay alternatively it allows us to
describe where is something's position
in relation to you or relation to
something else so I just like us to note
that down bearings are a consistent way
or a consistent system for describing
direction which way are you facing and
you can put this in brackets relative
position position was that word I kept
not mentioning yesterday when we
reintroduced trigonometry when we use
words like adjacent or opposite we're
talking about relative position right
how are things
located in relation to other things okay
there are two systems and they overlap
with each other bless you two sisters
for measuring bearing for describing
directions so underneath here I would
really like it if you could use a ruler
and draw for me to compass roses compass
roses in case you don't know what
compass roses look like they actually
look very very similar to Cartesian
planes at least before we put any labels
on them so here's my compass compass
roses here are my compass roses okay now
if these were the Cartesian planes we'd
say these were axes right x-axis y-axis
but because these are not Cartesian
planes I label everything very
differently on a map what direction
up north very good let's label that and
of course if we go around clockwise we
know that we should never eat soggy
weet-bix so there are all of your
compass directions I personally just
always remembered that Western Australia
is on that side the side that I'm not on
so that's why they're on the left so
this is our compass rose now you can see
I can go to an extra level of detail
because this is a very blunt instrument
right if something's like over here it's
not quite North it's not quite East it's
somewhere in between so that's why we
add in extra markings in here and I'm
going to grab another color so we can
talk about these with more specificity I
think is the appropriate word okay so if
I add in sort of an additional compass
rose which is headed or is rotated
rather 45 degrees off of the original
compass rose you can see in here I've
got extra measurements so the one that's
between north and east is north east the
one that's between South and East is and
you get the pattern right okay wonderful
now this is good this is an improvement
but you can still go a little bit
further because if you have a think
about it remember I said this divides up
everything into 45-degree chunks okay
which is why there are count them one
two three four five six seven eight
chunks this divides us into eight
different directions I can face that's
still very broad so what we can do is we
can add one more level of in-betweens so
for example you've got this one here
which is between north and northeast so
we call it north north east then you've
got this one here between east and
northeast
so that makes it east-northeast it
starts to get a little bit confusing
here because you've got so many letters
which is why after this level we don't
go any further this is as far as we go
when we're talking about these compass
directions okay so we can round this off
if you add in all the rest of the gaps
this one here is going to be east south
east south south east and you can keep
on going
okay that's quite pretty okay so you can
see this is a scheme that we can use
just like when we say ah it's quarter
past five in the evening or it's half
past one in the morning and you should
be getting to bed and this gives us very
rough approximation so you could say
yeah it's roughly in that time and these
compass directions are not bad for that
but clearly number one it starts to get
a bit overwhelming is we want to get
more detailed number two it's still not
that accurate like there's still lots of
spots in between where for example if
you walked if we all start at the same
spot one person walked northeast for 100
meters and another person walked east
northeast for a hundred meters those two
people even though all they've walked is
like what how's it taste to walk 100
meters maybe 20 seconds or something
like that
haven't walked very far at all but we're
going to be quite distant from each
other so not very much accuracy